questionner fin d'émission ce qu'est ce
que ces dix questions sont posées à tous
les invités de référence qui viennent
dans cette émission de parce que depuis
ses débuts voici ses dc10 question votre
mots préférés woody allen
notre mot m'a fait rire world mon
préféré
je peux pas vous le dire à la télévision
baboo a bon messi s'est dit lui aussi si
au contraire
non vraiment je ne peux pas pourquoi ma
mère ma mère regardent peut-être
l'émission on en a je ne peux pas et le
mot que vous détestez bonjour votre
drogue favorite favorite l'aspirine le
son le bruit que vous aimez fns
le bruit ce que je vais faire
oui peut-être un coup de coup de feu ah
bon et le coup de feu sur broadway et et
le son le bruit que vous détestez dont
je n'aime pas le son de ma voix votre
juron gros mots ou blasphème favori m'a
fait valoir
pourquoi on vous êtes en colère je ne
suis pas comme ça quand je suis en
colère je suis très désagréable quand je
suis en colère quand vous n'aimeriez pas
vous n'aimeriez pas cependant je peux
pas prendre de risques qu'une qu'un de
mes proches vous aimez être cher
m'entends dire ça non non non non c'est
trop non non non je peux pas vraiment
pas aimé c'est peut-être le premier mot
que vous vouliez pas prononcé à la
première question il ya ça même certes
il ya beaucoup d'autres mots petit que
vous avez aimé le métier que vous
n'auriez pas aimé faire oui jobs
le métier a good night by n'aurait pas
voulu que ce prêt jeune moine être
gardien de prison par exemple très bien
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné
bonne question
peut-être être réincarné en éponge
répond on éponge pour moi pour gonfler
ses robots c'était joli ses sympathies
l'eponge n'a pas d'ennemi pourquoi est
la dernière question qui est plus
difficile si dieu existe
c'est dieu existe qu aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire à vous
woody allen iphone et bio je te pardonne
et fissiles s'ils existent je pense que
je risque d'avoir de gros problèmes très
bien